I watched that video of young Elon Musk
on Instagram and he was just getting
delivery of a million dollar car I
thought it was a deep fake because he
just looked like Ralph Wiggum but with
you know
wow he really looked like this bad
Blazer and his hair looked terrible and
I was like that's a deep fake it wasn't
a deep fake it was him he was like wow
like three weeks ago I was sleeping in
my car now I have a million dollar car
and I was going like and you [__]
aren't happy like I can tell watching
this video like you're like here it is I
can't believe it's super cool car
when I talk about this all the time on
the Pod but it's like
we I talk about all the time having your
having your dreams come true and having
you know your needs met isn't the key to
happiness but I I want everyone to find
that out for themselves I want their
dreams to come true I want them to have
the things that they need of course but
I am there aren't any good examples of
an Elon Musk or whoever that just goes
like and you know the emptiness came
with me I got in the car I drove around
is this even his voice drove around hey
I'm buying it yeah I buy it too because
he's so not loved like no one cares like
if he was a beloved figure I think
the rising ground in the community
doesn't like what this impression right
now but like there's not a lot we don't
even have to get into that it's that
that's my sadness is I get really sad
when I see people that like even with
every privilege are still just kind of
like hungry ghosts is what they're
called in Buddhism you know he could be
happy and he that's just he's not he's
not able to show emotion as well well
who the [__] am I you know that's
absolutely true maybe that was that was
like that's the most excited
about you know what you sound a little a
little Icelandic I got up to Iceland
twice a month to buy my cigarettes I
love all your impressions you have such
range
you do yeah I can only do Icelandic I
everyone has an Icelandic way you know
it's like Dr Evil yeah everybody house
that's how I do it icelanders hate it
and
if it is the only thing I have the one
thing how did you find your Iceland I
think you just tighten your the back of
your throat I don't know maybe it's it's
close to Japanese a little bit do you
speak Japanese I do yeah conversational
yeah I've lost a lot of the ability you
mean like no poetic Japanese yes you
used to have some poetry in you oh yeah
yeah yeah oh yes the poetic Japanese is
gone I I talk very like just you know
very second grade level just like give
me this give me that like I'm like a
Russian
man I have a Japanese stereotype that
people would just be like
it's also Russian you're right but there
are certain cultures where it's not rude
to just be like give me eat this yes yes
please eat this now I think it's broken
English but I'm just saying like even in
Japanese it sounds very like yeah yeah
well correct me if I'm wrong but it's
not as flowery as we're like hey y'all
we're gonna have her
favorite restaurant in Japan it's like I
don't want to do the impression but I
actually I really do but I don't want to
get in trouble but it's like you know
it's time right here is that right it's
true it's so true I never even thought
about that I never thought what you just
did with the hey y'all booming onion I
never thought that that was
flowery it's musical it is westerners
sing their words which is why when
everybody sings they sound Western
oh geez I love playing Bono and he's
like where the streets have no name like
where's it go interesting I did not know
that I always wondered like yeah
Australian and people like that I don't
understand on until they're singing and
wow goes away because we're singing all
the time I thought it's because they all
have the ability to talk like in an
American English accent normal
talk the right way I'll talk correctly
talk the right way I didn't know I
thought they always had the ability but
you know we have a hard time trying to
sound like Australians and British
people yes of course because it sounds
like an affection an affectation to us
like we're adding something about what
is the word for them it's taking it away
right to Val Val's very good at helping
me realize where I'm being short-sighted
ethnocentric or something it's the
assumption that your culture is the
Baseline yes I caught myself doing I had
a bit I was in Australia and I was like
you guys realize you're talking wrong
like you're talking wrong like right now
you and oh it's not you that's wrong
yeah like and she and they liked it
because I think they're laughing at me
basically
right because they also know you're
being like you know I'm saying anything
I'm not supposed to yeah yeah yeah but
because I'm saying that there's actually
kind of something loving about that like
look at this dumb thing yeah right
[Music]